shocking new video tonight of a
journalist being attacked on the job
surveillance video showing the man being
accosted and forcibly removed from a
public speaking event for none other
than American urban radio networks and
CNN's April Ryan who ironically is known
to be a champion for press freedom watch
this
don't you dare put that down sir joining
me now exclusively is the man in that
video it's Charley kratochvíl the editor
of New Brunswick today
all right so Charley you went into this
event where April Ryan was going to be
speaking you wanted to cover it from a
straight news perspective you got
credentialed no one ever told you or it
was never written anywhere that there
was no filming and then what happened
yeah I was there with my camera on a
tripod right next to another camera on a
tripod
I enjoyed the evening for the first
couple hours and then this fellow came
up to me and started you know asking me
who I was where you know why is your
camera here and I gave my business card
explained and he came back and told me
you know if I don't take that camera
down he'll take it down for me one thing
led to another he grabbed the camera and
and hightailed it out of the room were
you the only one that was booted out or
were other people there left to film I
was the only one and I wasn't really
booted I voluntarily left because he
stole my camera so other people were
able to film and you weren't precisely
there were other people taking videos
other people taking pictures and maybe
they mistook you for me I don't know
what what the the misunderstanding was
but I was definitely you know felt
violated so this this was a bodyguard
you believe of April Ryan yes that's
what the police were told they said this
was Miz Ryan's security guard
Joel Morris this is Joel Morris and he
put his hands on you absolutely yeah
what did he do specifically physically
to you so I was able to retrieve the
camera as you might have seen in the
video and then he just won't give me any
space and he stays right near me I'm
trying to use the camera to get an image
of him to make sure I get a document
who he is and he doesn't want that to
happen so he's sticking his hand in the
in the face of the camera and touching
you know hitting the microphone and and
I kind of snuck away to get some space
from him and he chased me down grabbed
my arm twisted my arm behind my back and
hurt my shoulder and for Wow
and you're not an ideological opponent
of miss Ryan when I left the house that
day I was a fan of her as I was looking
forward to seeing her remarks and you
know maybe learning a thing or two since
she's been a journalist longer than I
have so the press attacked freedom of
the press in your opinion this was an
attack on our freedoms yes absolutely
and and it cannot stand and we reached
out to comment to hear from April Ryan
she has not exercised her First
Amendment rights and neither has CNN
neither has American urban radio
networks and unfortunately she's just
going to try to ride this out I guess
and pretend like it never happened even
though it's all over the Internet and I
think we have a tweet from her from a
little while back and we put this tweet
up it says I have never seen anything
like this in this country by a president
as in his administration
speaking of Trump freedom of the press
we are not in Russia or China our jobs
are to ask questions a lot of times
questions they don't like what in the
world that's from last July and she's
accusing the Trump administration of
being like China and Russia and then in
August 20 1977 OHS journalism somebody
who's been in the field for a long time
she wouldn't want to be treated like
that so I don't see why she can come
into my community and you know have her
people come and violate our laws like
that and and you know attack freedom of
the press this was absolutely an attack
on a journalist who was just there to do
his job all right Charlie thanks very
much I appreciate it thank you for
showing light on